Another technique that's based on behavioral principals is systematic
desensitization. This is used in treatment of phobias. This technique pairs the
event that produces the anxiety with a stimulus that elicits an incompatible
response such as relaxation. This is referred to as counterconditioning. For
example, think back to when we introduced Tickles the snake. Snakes are a
common phobia for individuals. And for a person who has a phobia of snakes, if
they saw one, he or she would experience uncomfortable levels of anxiety. With
systematic desensitization, the therapist would create a hierarchy of stimuli
snakes. So, for example, they may have a client just imagine looking at a
snake. But while doing so, the therapist teaches the client how to relax. These
relaxation techniques in turn are then used by the client when exposed to
stimuli on the hierarchy. This approach relies on reciprocal inhibition which
is the underlying process of counterconditioning. And it states that certain
responses are incompatible with each other. So with this, the occurrence of one
response inhibits the other. For example, you can't be relaxed and anxious at
the same time. Systematic desensitization is a very effective treatment for
phobias and is widely used.